thank you so this is about some
new recent work in
spectral graph theory
so the study of applications of linear
algebra to the study of
graph properties and graph algorithms
so the connection between
graphs and linear algebra comes from the
fact that
one can very naturally
associate matrices to
graphs most naturally the adjacency
matrix of a graph
and as has been
known for
for a long time there are several
connections between
linear algebraic
properties of the decency matrix and
combinatorial properties of the graph
so the
eigenvalues of the matrix say several
interesting things about commentary
properties of the graph and usually
those connections have constructive
proofs
which show that given the eigenvectors
of the adjacency matrix one can also
construct efficient algorithms for graph
problems
in fact instead of the adjacency matrix
it's often easier to work with a
normalized version of the distance
matrix it's called the
laplacian and this matrix is
symmetric
if the graph is undirected
so that means that all the eigenvalues
are real and here are some basic facts
about the eigenvalues of these matrix
and now they relate to computer
properties of the graph and then we will
explore various generalizations of those
basic facts
so one effect of this normalization is
that regardless of the size of the graph
and the degree of the graph all the
eigenvalues of this matrix are between 0
and 2. without the normalization they
will be in a range that depends on the
average degree of the graph
and and also
zero is always achieved as an eigenvalue
two may or may not
the two uh
basic facts have been known for a long
time but are already fairly surprising
are that um the number of uh
times that zero occurs as an eigenvalue
of this matrix so the multiplicity with
which it occurs is precisely the number
of quantity components of the graph
so zero occurs always at least once and
if it occurs twice the graph is
disconnected if it occurs exactly four
times the graph has precisely four
quantity components
the other fact is that on the other end
of the spectrum
two may or may not be achieved as an
eigenvalue and it's achieved only when a
graph is bipartite
or
one of its quantity components is
byproduct so two of the most fundamental
graph properties connectivity and tool
colorability are captured by the list of
eigenvalues of the laplacian matrix
they're also captured by the list of
eigenvalues of the adjacency matrix but
this normalization makes the statements
well then it says that none of the
quantity components of the graph
are bipartite does it give you a
measurement of some kind
well um
thanks for for this question
my first work in spectrograph theory was
to show that
the gap between two and lambda and if
any
shows how far from bipartite are all
subset of vertices of the graph so if
there is a gap for every subset of
vertices for every way of trying to
bipartite them there will be some
violating edges and if this gap is
epsilon an epsilon fraction of those
edges will be violating conversely if
the gap is small it's possible to find a
subset of vertices
that can
there is almost this quantity from the
rest of the graph and that is almost
bipartite and the number of violating
edges will be root epsilon as a fraction
of the total if the gap here is less
than epsilon
so to see some um
example things that one can just read
from the list of um eigenvalues if i
tell you that i picked some graph and i
computed the list of uh eigenvalues and
it's like this you can already say what
is the graph with 10 vertices because
there are 10 eigenvalues
it's connected because 0 appears only
once and it's not bipartite
in fact this is a graph that has those
eigenvalues
while if you
look at the graph with this list of
eigenvalues you can say that it has
precisely two quantity components
and that neither of them is bipartite
and that it has
eight vertices
um
while a graph that has this list of
eigenvalues it's a graph that is
connected
and
it is bipartite
so let me
describe the
proof of the characterization of
the number of quantity components of the
graph as the number of times that zero
occurs as an eigenvalue
because that will be something that we
will then look at various
generalizations of
so the best characterization of
eigenvalues to
work out this connection
it's not as roots of the
characteristic polynomial but as
solutions of optimization problems in
the variational characterization which
is true for
medium matrices so in particular it's
true for real valued matrices that are
symmetric
and when we have an
undirected graph it's adjacency matrix
and its laplacian matrix
will be real-valued matrices that are
symmetric
okay so if a matrix is symmetric and
real valued then all the eigenvalues are
real
if we list them with multiplicities then
the kth smallest eigenvalue is
characterized this way
it's
this
optimal solution of this min max problem
where you look at
many
possible vectors that
all of them making these ratios more
so lambda k is the minimum overall k
dimensional choices of vectors
for which
the quadratic four normalized by the
norm of x is all small
and the optimum space for each k
is spanned by the eigenvalues of lambda
one up to lambda k
now the laplacian matrix um instead of
reverse engineered so that
this quantity over
whose optimization gives the eigenvalues
of the
of a matrix as a nice form in terms of
the graph
so uh
the quantity that one optimizes to
compute eigenvalues of the laplacian
it's something where for a given vector
you look over the edges of the graph
how much the vector gives
different values to the endpoints on the
edge so the average of this decent
square
normalized by
the summation of uh
so
a sort of l2 norm of the vector but
normalized by the degree
okay so this means that the eigenvalues
of the laplacian they are the min max
solution of
with this cost function
and notice that
this cost function can be zero
only when or precisely one x is a vector
that is constant on quantity components
of the graph
because for this quantity to be zero
it's a sum of squares every term must be
zero so that means that for every edge
xu and xv must be the same
so for every path
all the vertices along the path must be
the same so for every quantity
components all the vertices in the
quantity components must be the same
so if a graph has k or more quantity
components we can immediately see that
lambda k
is zero because as a
key dimensional space a solution to this
problem we can pick the space of all
vectors
that are constant on quantity components
so this would be k dimensional or more
and for all of them this quantity will
be zero so the maximum will be zero
so if
you have a graph with k or more quantity
components
lambda k of the laplacian will have to
be zero
the other direction is also easy to show
but i want to show
a
sort of not the shortest proof but one
that will give some intuition about
various generalizations
so suppose we have a graph in which
lambda k is zero we want to show that
there are k or more quantity components
okay
now let's look at the
eigenvectors of lambda 1 up to lambda k
so those will all be
vectors in this space a
and
for which this max is zero so this will
all be vectors for which this expression
is zero so those are all vectors that
are orthogonal to each other and that
are constant on quantity components
now
define
this mapping
of vertices of the graph
into a k-dimensional real space
so every eigenvector
is associating a number to each vertex
if you have k eigenvectors you have k
numbers for every vertex so think of
this association as being an embedding
of vertices into a k dimensional
now when you look at each coordinate of
this mapping
so that coordinate will have to be the
same value for a
for every two vertices that are in the
same quantity component
so in fact the whole mapping will have
to give the same output for two vertices
that are in the same quantity component
because this will be true coordinate by
coordinate
so if two vertices are in the same
quantity component this mapping maps
them to the same point
so if you have two vertices mapped to
two different points they must be in
different quantity components
okay
now how did we get
how did we get this mapping
so we
we started from those a
k n dimensional vectors
so just think of them as being
you know kind of k
row vectors of dimension n and then we
turn this k by n matrix around and now
we have
n
k dimensional vectors and those are our
points
since we
these k vectors are linearly independent
this scaled by an metric says full rank
so it cannot be that when you look at
its
columns or rows once it's flipped over
you only see k minus one different rows
and this would violate the
rank condition would easily
make you find the linear dependency
between those vectors
so the
this mapping must map points to at least
must map vector vertices to at least k
different points
and the pre-image of each of those
points it's a distinct quantity
component or union of connected
components so you have at least k
quantity components
all right now
we want to look at
various ways in which this
connection can be generalized
particularly
so this is an extremely result it says
the smallest that an eigenvalue can be
is zero
and if lambda k
is zero here is uh what happens we have
k quantity components so a robust
version of this result would be
something that characterizes the cases
in which lambda k is small instead of
being zero and so that's what we want to
talk about
uh so in order to
talk about this we also need a
generalization of the notion of a set of
vertices being disconnected from the
rest of the graph
and to
and kind of a quantitative version of
this
and the notion of conductance will work
well in in this connection so if we have
a set of vertices in a graph
its conductance it's
the fraction of edges incident on the
set that leave the set roughly so it's a
number of edges that leave the set
divide by the sum of the degrees
of the vertices in the set
an operational way of thinking about it
is that if we pick a random vertex in s
and then move with probability
proportional to the degree and then move
to a random neighbor the probability of
leaving s is precisely the conductance
of s
and then the conductance of the graph
it's the minimum overall
partitions of the vertex set into two
parts of the conductance of the small
side of the cut
so for example is a graph of conductance
zero
this set has conductance zero and so
that's the complement
this is a
graph of small conductance
but asymptotically the conductance of an
n cycle is order one over n
and this is a graph with very big
conductance the
the smallest connecting set is
a smallest conductance set is the set of
five inner vertices the total degree is
15 and there are five edges going out it
only as much as a third of the edges is
coming out
i notice that here the second eigen
value is fairly large
well here the second eigenvalue was
really small
actually
this definition
of conductance of
a set
defines an optimization problem of
finding the smallest conductance set
which is very interesting in its own
right
so if for example the
undirected graph
describes a social network then a low
conductance subset of the graph
is say a subset of conductance 0.1 the
set of users that on average have 90
percent of their friends in the set so
it's a very tightly bound community
and
if a graph is constructed starting from
a data set by having one vertex for each
data item
and then the weight of an edge to be
a measure of similarity between the
items then look on that and set is a set
of items that are much more similar to
each other than to anything else so in
some cases this is a appropriate
definition of clustering
and also
in some cases finding balanced
low conductance cuts can be useful to
get um
exponential time but sort of faster than
brute force algorithms for
np heart problems
for example
in planar graphs one can solve
most of our problems in time to the root
and
because of the fact that one can always
find
cuts of conductance
order one over rutan
and in general finding local atoms
balanced cut can give significant
improvements over
brute force
okay so the uh
one way in which immediately one can see
the conductance relates to the spread
room of the graph is that
one can have
a
non-trivial multiplicity of zero if and
only if the graph is disconnected
a graph is connected if and only if
there is a cut of conductance zero
so lambda two and the conductance are
zero exactly in the same cases
and the trigger inequality
for graphs
states that
the conductance of a graph and
the second eigenvalue of the laplacian
they are
sort of approximations of each other
so one is small if and only if the other
is small one is large if and only if the
other is large up to this quadratic gap
which is tight
and the proof of the upper bound is
constructive
in a following sense that given an
eigenvector of lambda 2 in fact any
vector for which the rayleigh quotient
is small
one can run the following algorithm
so this vector will give
an assignment of numbers two vertices
use these numbers as keys to sort the
vertices
and then consider all the initial
segments of the sorted order
and pick
the initial set of vertices for which
the conductance is smallest
this set will be a set of conductance at
most square root of 2 lambda 2. so in
particular the graph will have
connections at most this much but
because of the other direction of the
inequality this also says that the set
found by this very efficient algorithm
as conductance
that is at most
two square root of the optimum so it's
also an approximation algorithm which in
fact works very well on average usually
better than predicted by this inequality
even though there are graphs for which
this is tight
you have to find the vector
yes but um with the new
laplacian solvers you can do even that
in early linear time
so there are many ways in which these
inequalities are useful so the
so used by different communities
one way is that it's a worst case
analysis of this algorithm that sorts
vertices according to the eigenvector of
lambda
this is an algorithm that
was
suggested by fiddler even in the 70s
before this analysis
to construct
expanders so graphs of large conductance
usually the analysis of
the proof that the graph is large
conductance is the hard part
and it's often convenient to listen
about the spectrum of the graph instead
of listening about the conductance
but some other times the opposite is
true
so it's known that to analyze the mixing
time random works in graphs
so what one needs to compute is lambda 2
of the laplacian of the graph of the
uh
and in some but
lambda 2 and the conductance are
approximations of
each other so if i want to prove that
random works converge quickly
which means one needs to prove a lower
bound or lambda two in some cases it can
be easier to prove a lower bound on the
conductance and that's how
say with the method of the canonical
paths and sometimes this is easier
okay so coming to
our work we were interested in
getting a robust version
of the fact that lambda is zero if and
only if gsk or more quantitative
components the trigger inequality is a
robust version of this for k equal to
that says lambda 2 is small if and only
if
g can be partitioned into the vertices
can be partitioned into two sets giving
a cut of small conductance
and our result qualitatively is that
lambda k is small if and only if
one can find in the graph k or more
disjoint sets of vertices each one
having small conductance okay so for k
equal to is the trigger inequality for
larger k it gives a new characterization
so to
make this
qualitative
statement quantitative we define a
generalization of conductance
uh so we call the order k conductance
the minimum overall choices of k
disjoint sets
of the maximum conduct conductance of
the sets that we picked
so they're the k conductance is small if
and only if you can find k these joint
sets each of small conductance
and for k equal to that's the
conductance and for larger k
one observation is that this quantity is
zero if and only if g has k quantity
components or more yeah
both definitions are interesting
the two numbers are of by factor of k
so for example this is a
a graph of large
order three conductance even though it
has conductance zero when you try to
divide your stuff into three parts
at least one part will have many edges
living
it is a graph for small order three
conductance
so quantitatively our theorem is that
the order k conductance
e and lambda k are approximations of
each other
up to the same quadratic loss that comes
up also in the trigger
inequality and then these are these
other laws which is order of k squared
this can be significant when one looks
at say the root and eigenvalue
and the
upper bound is constructive meaning that
if one gives us
the eigenvectors of lambda 1 up to
lambda k
in nearly linear time
instead of the graph polynomial time in
k we can find the k disjoint sets that
witness this upper bound
and
if you allow some
gap between
how many sets we're looking for and how
many eigenvalues are small
this
loss of k squared becomes root lo k
which is known to be best possible this
was also approved by luis raghavendra
italian vimpal
now
so one
one aspect of the proof both of our but
our proof and the proof of louise
another
is that
it says something although um so it
doesn't give a complete analysis but it
says something about an algorithm for a
clustering that
works very well in practice
so this an algorithm
does the following it's given a
graph and a parameter k
then it computes the eigenvectors
corresponding to the smallest
eigenvalues of the laplacian
then computes the mapping that also
defined before when i was proving that
when lambda k is zero you have k
quantity components or more
so it uses those k eigenvectors to map
vertices into k dimensional points
then it forgets all about the edges of
the graph just looks at this set of
endpoints in k dimensional space
and
it tries to cluster them into k clusters
with some geometric algorithm usually
they apply k-means
so this is an algorithm that comes up in
so that part of computer science doesn't
work quite like theory where we start
from a problem
and then we sign an algorithm and then
we prove or show by experiments that the
algorithm solves the problem
this is more like the result of data
then
we apply this algorithm to the data the
results are interesting
and then that means that the algorithm
works but it's not like there is a
problem and algorithm solves the problem
uh but one thing that is provably
is the following suppose that you
construct a
random graph in a following way you
start from three disjoint sets of
vertices here i
draw them with different colors
and then you pick edges at random but
with high probability
within
the same
set and with low probability uh between
so here the probability of edges between
different colors was two percent inside
was 20 percent just to get an example
now um take this graph
and
um
find
and apply this algorithm for k equal
three
so this will find the three-dimensional
mapping of vertices
into a three-dimensional space
and this is what this mapping will look
like
um in these mappings one dimension
always maps all vertices to the same
constant so a k dimensional mapping is
really intrinsically chemists one
dimension so a three-dimensional mapping
is actually this mapping in the plane
the algorithm that does this mapping has
no idea what the colors of the vertices
are just use a graph
but it does tend to push together the
vertices that we connected with our
probability and to push apart the
vertices we connected with lower
probability so it if you now
forget about the edges and just apply
some geometric partitioning algorithm
maybe with a couple of outliers you will
find out what were the three sets that
you started from
so in fact this can be established
rigorously that if you construct if you
plant a k clustering in a graph by
starting from k sets
connecting within sets with a
probability between sets with low
probability
this mapping will tend to
push vertices in the same cluster
together but in different clusters apart
and then facilitate geometric algorithms
but um
whether it would be interesting to
understand a little bit better is for
general graphs
what problem is this algorithm solving
and why it
tends to work well
so both in
our truth and in the result of lewis and
daughter when we want to find
k low conductance sets whenever they
exist
the first step of our algorithms is to
do exactly the same mapping
then we don't apply
k means to this mapping and
what they do is more like partitioning
the space into k cons and then taking
each of them
and we partition it into many more cones
and then patch them together
but it does give at least a first
understanding that for arbitrary graphs
this mapping is discovering something
and then applying geometric algorithms
to this embedding is a sort of sound
process
alessandra you have the question are you
saying that for this random
graph or random graphs i guess with
different probabilities it recovers
exactly
what depends on the problem exactly the
difference in probabilities between
yeah of course but how much is the let's
say p is the probability within each
color and q is across
what's the difference that it recovers
exactly with high variability
um
maybe it has to be like log over router
and i'm not sure um
there is baby by and jordan invice would
actually give
a more general analysis they say suppose
you have a graph
and in your graph you have k sets of
vertices
each set of vertex is an expander
within sets of vertices you have few
edges
but i don't remember what are the
thresholds but each other versus an
expander between sets you have few edges
and then there is a technical thing like
in every set every vertex has more
neighborhoods inside the side than
outside the set
under those three conditions this
algorithm will find the sets
exactly and this is pretty
i remember that this was with matrix
perturbation yes it's pretty weak in the
sense of the parameters
it will not work with
very sparse graphs
yeah on the size of the clusters right
as you can encode
then i think it's one of the route
the difference is
okay traditionally the speaker talks
so let's see that
well let's
see
to the conservative yeah
sometimes here
so let me state one more result then we
can
talk to each other in the break so
coming back to the
trigger inequality the standard case for
cable two
so as i said this quadratic class is
necessary for some graphs
but it seems to
so this worst case analysis seems to
not do justice to how well the algorithm
working works in practice
so the other result i want to
talk about is a
maybe tightening of this inequality
where we show that for every k the
conductance of the graph is always at
most order of k
times lambda 2 divided by root log k
root lambda k so when k is 2
that's the same inequality actually
this constant maybe will become 8 inside
of root 2.
but it is saying that if you have a
graph where there is a sparse cut so
lambda 2 is small
but maybe lambda 5 is fairly large maybe
it's an absolute constant
then
what you get is a constant factor
approximation
where the constant will depend on
how large is k and how large is root
lambda k
and the upper bound is achieved by the
standard uh algorithm the one that uses
only an eigenvector of lambda 2 doesn't
know anything about lambda k or about
eigenvectors okay
so this is also an improved analysis of
the sweep algorithm it says
the set found by the sweep algorithm is
such that for every k its conductance is
at most the optimal conductance
times this is something like
2 2 or maybe 4 like it's a really small
constant times k divided by root lambda
and algebraic doesn't know anything
about
lambda 3 lambda 4 and so on so if you
have a graph for which for some k this
ratio is bounded
that's a graph on which the sweep
argument will do better than so the
standard analysis
it's an absolute constant this is like
four times k times lambda over root
lambda four times greater than zero i
think it's two root two uh
but it's it's no more than ten
it's not a different constant for every
k no no no order of k
no no no
this is like no more than ten times k
times
okay
there's no tilde
right so let uh
so the proof goes through a structure
theorem that maybe is interesting in uh
on its own
um
which says the following uh
for every
so if x is an eigenvector of lambda 2
it's always possible to find some other
vector y
that is not too far from x if lambda k
is bigger than lambda 2.
and such that
y when you look at its entries contains
only two k different values
okay so
if there is a big gap between lambda 2
and lambda k
the eigenvector of lambda 2
is
kind of it's kind of discrete it's not
close to having not too many different
values
right so that's not the way the
agave between the cycle looks like like
there
when you look at the various entries you
sort of see a smooth
if you sort them you see a very smooth
growth
while
in graphs which is a gap between
laminator and lambda k
so if you sort the vertices by value
you're going to see chunks or
up to some noise
okay
uh and then
if you sort vertices by
how they appear in the
in the cycle yeah it says in the side if
you start vertices by
the value they get in the eigenvector
you'll see a smoothly growing function
so then the second part is that
by 2k value vector you're talking about
the
coordinates
yeah if you look at the coordinates the
values of the coordinates of y you only
observe at most 2k different values
and then the second part is that
if you apply the sweep algorithm to an
eigenvector x that is chunky in this
sense that can be well approximated by
a discrete vector
then you get some improvement over the
standard trigger inequality so in
particular if this distance is very
small
the quadratic loss sort of disappears
and you just get order of k times lambda
2
if this approximation is poor you still
get root lambda 2 as usual
so those are the
so when you combine those two together
you get the statement that they claimed
so for the
for the first part which is more
interesting this structure theorem some
intuition for why something like this
might be believable
uh is to look at what happens in the
extremal case so the most so the biggest
gap you can have between lambda 2 and
lambda k
is that
say lambda 2 is
0 and lambda k is positive so then this
ratio will be 0.
so what happens when lambda 2 is 0 and
lambda k is positive
so then
x is constant on quantity components
but if lambda k is positive you only
have k minus 1 connected components or
fewer
so x can only have k minus one different
values so it's it's
you don't need any approximation to say
that it has only cameras one different
values right so it's a distance zero
from some vector that has only k minus
one different values
so what we need to prove is a robust
version of this
so the proofs that it works
in the following way we again think of x
of
the eigenvector x is being a
mapping of
vertices to the line
and then we
divide the line into two k intervals
oh well it's a vector with one
coordinate for every vertex so you have
a real number for every vertex you can
think of it this way
so that we divide the line into
intervals
so in a in a way that will make sure
that
within each intervals the points are
roughly
equally far from the boundaries
these are some techniques
and then we will construct the
approximating vector
by
looking for every vertex
where it's mapped
on the line and what's the closest
interval boundary to it
so then what we need to
argue is that if lambda k is large
this rounding will not
require a lot of moving around of
vertices
will not create a new
assignment of real numbers to vertices
very far from what we had before
and equivalently what we need to show is
that if
this rounding
requires us to move a lot
we can find the witness the lambda k was
small
and we find the witness lambda k is
small in that case by finding k
digitally supported vectors each of them
having small really quotient
and basically each of those
vectors will be supported only
supporting meaning nonzero
only on the vertices that belong to each
of the intervals
and so when you need to move
when you have lots of intervals where
lots of points are far from the
boundaries
um
this process will construct vectors with
small daily quotient
then for
for the other result
so this is what we need to show that if
we have
a
vector
x
approximated by some other vector y
that is only a bonding number of
distinct values
the performance of the sweep algorithm
will be
you know with a quadratic loss but
multiplied by the distance
and then a linear loss which would be
optimum
and what we have to work with is the
standard proof that gives all this
equality class
regardless of distance
and
an observation that
if you if the vector x itself has only k
different values when you do the sweep
algorithm you only lose a factor of k
so now we need to
bring together the ideas in this proof
and in this proof
and
this is sort of an interpolation of the
two arguments
actually maybe i should have let people
talk because i'm going a bit faster than
i was planning but
sorry
so another
kind of question
i want to briefly mention is
to get a robust version of
this statement
so the
characterization of number of quality
components in terms of
multiplicity of zero it says that
you have that lambda k of the laplacian
is zero lambda k plus one is positive
precisely when
gsk quantity components
so um
a robust version would be a
characterization of what happens when
there is a big gap between lambda k and
lambda k plus one
or see what happens when lambda is small
lambda k plus one is large
there was a result of tanaka
that proved that
with a large enough gap
between lambda k and lambda k plus one
so this gap needs to be quadratic
but also exponential in k
so then the following happens um
that it's so we know that
when
lambda k is small
we can find k sides of small conductance
and so he does
but then with this condition he can also
show that each set of each of those k um
so first of all he gets a partition
and
each of the sets in this partition
induces a subgraph that has large
conductance
large dependent on lambda k plus one
so what you get
is that the graph looks like there are
cases of vertices each one induces an
expander
and
each one has few edges coming out
so that
so gives a pretty strong structure
theorem for what the graph looks like it
also says that you cannot hope to get a
partition into k plus one sets each of
small conductance because any such
partition we need to break one of the
expanders
yes it is a strong assumption but there
is also a strong conclusion so to some
extent one would guess that
um
but but it's true it's strong in two
ways there is a quadratic gap between
lambda and k plus one
and then
this exponential means that when k is
more than logan this statement is not
really saying anything
we don't know
um
but um it's like winning the lottery
it's unlikely but you'll be very happy
if you get it
what is the meaning of it
oh induced means that you look at the
subgraph that has the vertices in that
set and then all the edges that have
both end points in that set so it's
vertex induced
yes i'm not sure if it makes sense but
is there any chance this might follow
from what you already proved about like
lambda k being small
then you have you know k
components
and from the results you first mentioned
the beginning of the talk
yeah no it's not a little clear that
each set needs to be
an expander
combined with number k plus one oh yeah
even if you plus one is big it's not
clear
i mean
somehow if you know this then you know
that it has to be the case because then
the partition is unique
but from our argument it doesn't really
follow the substance to be expanded
and also this argument is very
non-constructive i mean not non-custrati
it's non-algorithmic
he finds this partition by repeatedly
finding cuts of optimal conductance and
in the argument he
needs
the cut to be of optimal conductance to
get some contradiction there
okay so in
um kind of recent work we just completed
um
we
get something somewhat tighter um
in
the following way so first of all if we
have a gap in the order ka conductance
versus order k plus one conductance
this gap can really be arbitrarily small
uh we get the same conclusion
so there are there is a partition in two
case subsets
each subset has is a subset of low
conductance where load depends on 5k
and
each
set in this partition
induces
a large conductance subgraph where large
depends on phi k plus one
and uh um
this will prove by a non-constructive uh
argument anyway is also a condition that
we don't know how to test those are all
npr to compute quantities
but
with a sufficiently large gap between
the eigen values
we can recover the conclusion
algorithmically
as in tanaka we have the quadratic gap
it's still not clear if this quadratic
gap is necessary
uh but the dependence on k goes from
exponential to polynomial
and here this was exponential time
computation is the point of the time
computation
does follow from your previous results
right no
to get this in the quality to get the
sufficient condition from there sorry we
use the viewers result but uh
it also needs something more so we still
don't know how to say that
what we get from the previous result is
a collection of sets each of them
inducing an expander but then we do a
post-processing that will uh enforce
that you can get a weaker result
one condition yeah
so
that
uh
implies the previous one right the fine
capacitor yes
okay that's using your result
so once uh once we approve this
once we approve this
our pre-result implies that
under this condition then the existence
of the partition follows
however it doesn't follow that we can
find it algorithmically because it could
still be that that partition is not the
same that is found by the algorithm
so that's it can you generate the
example first of all should presumably
be omega but
yeah
you can make the jump this but to jump
as much as you want like if
yeah i mean you can have lambda k be one
over n lambda k plus one be a constant
you can do whatever you want
you could be like then then
then we always knew how to listen
yeah yeah
yes
yes
okay
as i've mentioned um
one more
point of view on
the generalized sugar inequality that i
described before
which is that
um that improved analysis of the sugar
inequality
that's improved only if it's a graph in
which lambda k is large for some k
otherwise
that ratio k
lambda 2 over root lambda k is not
better than the original analysis
but graphs in which lambda k is large
for small k
are graphs for which we know
several algorithms that perform better
than general graphs
and in fact uh
for a sort of pretty weak
notion of large one can find constant
factor approximation or even one plus
epsilon uh approximation for minimal
conductance sets in time that is
exponential in k
so we can see this improved analysis of
the sweep algorithm as a kind of
trade-off where
instead of getting this constant or one
perception approximation we get some
k over root lambda k approximation but
the running time is linear instead of
exponentially in k
and
we also have another kind of
instantiation of this trade-off
between running time and approximation
which is that under conditions similar
to the one where here you get constant
factor approximation in time exponential
in k
we can get
root log k approximation
in fixed polynomial time
from the same relaxation used by royal
bazirani
by showing that when lambda k is large
a different rounding from the original
aurora 171 will do a better job
okay so i would like to
and by
discussing um direction that i think
could lead to interesting results
although i don't have any
um con
precise conjecture to state
which is that uh so to find
other results that justify also explain
the good performance of the
sweep algorithm on many instances
so we have this general worst case
analysis
and then the analysis that i mentioned
before
improves
the upper bound in graphs where lambda k
is large
but i think it would be really
interesting to have
an analysis
so this analysis fails on many
interesting graphs for example this
doesn't say anything about the cycle
even though the sweep algorithm will
find an optimal cut in the cycle
so the thing is that the cycle is one of
those cases where it's not the upper
bound it's not tight it's the lower
bound that is not tight
in a cycle the conductance is 1 over n
lambda 2 is 1 over n squared
so because there is a big gap between
lambda 2 and phi the upper bound gives
you a actually good approximation
and
in fact something like this is known for
all planar graphs
it's known that in all boundary degree
planar graphs lambda 2 is order 1 over n
it has a highly nontrivial upper bound
which means that without touching the
upper bound
you immediately
on the performance on the algorithm you
immediately get that on every planar
graph the sweep algorithm will find a
cut of conductance at most order one of
rutan which is tight for the grid
and matches the planar severe theorem in
bonnie degree graphs
so this is something that
so it's not saying that on every planet
graph you get a good approximation
because if you have two grids connected
by an edge
you're still getting a very poor
approximation
but
so what i think would be
really interesting is to find some class
of graphs
on which there is a provable gap on all
the graphs in the class between lambda 2
and the conductance
so then just plugging this back into the
upper bound will tell you that you have
a
less than quadratic clause
in
in the algorithm
so maybe this is too much to prove it
could be that you have a class of graphs
in which
you can
either
establish
a gap or uh show that some other
algorithm will do well
or so cleaner
no
in a planar like if you have
two grids with one edge
the expansion will be 1 over n lambda 2
will be 1 over n
but maybe
you can say
you know either some other algorithm
works well or
you have a gap
yeah so i don't have a precise
conjecture but i think it's
it's a direction
worth investigating i haven't really
seen
i don't know
h
yeah but it doesn't show that
um you have a class of manifolds in
which lambda is very small
it just gives you an analog of these
four manifolds in which you have a bunny
curvature
yeah so i i think it's a
it's a pretty wide open
kind of question
okay that's all i wanted to talk about
thanks
i know we already had some discussion so
perhaps
one day there's several application
several applications of the fact that
they were the
large first value when you have huge
graphs of exponential size like
in the most famous is for a approximate
sampling and the counting will have a
similarity and another application
is for optimization to do one more walk
and then
cut the other point
for the main work cut again but and the
question is can you do
something especially for the second
question i mean it might be hopeful
when you have some condition on the
when you don't have the expansion
the necessary expansion that you don't
have the nice behavior for the first
item they do but you have nice behavior
for the other
well what you can say is that like if
say lambda is large
that for many or at least for some start
vertices
the random walk
will get to pretty high rainy entropy
fairly quickly
right so then it might fail to
to actually mix
in fact you know maybe the graph is
disconnected
but that's something that uh potentially
you have let's say the gap is connected
so
you need some property
to walk hereditary whenever you say you
have some objective function on the so
you need some property which will be for
any satsabra which is above the value of
the objective function the question is
there some property in terms of the
which is weaker than just the first
eigenvalue will be involved
i don't know i mean there are a lot of
pieces to your question you want to
iterate
above any value of the of the
attainable the graph induced by this
vertices is an expander then we can
optimize very quickly
so the question is can we relax if
if the graph above any value satisfy
some
weaker condition which involved the
other likelihood
ah so
maybe that's a case in which those
relaxations
would
work so i'm not sure what's the setting
that you're thinking about but um
so like yeah so some of the algorithms
that you would say well
so if i have a
constrained
satisfaction problem with two variables
per constraint the constraint graph is
an expander so in some cases you can
you know can do things more quickly if
instead of being an expander lambda k is
large then you can still
do something but
yeah
i don't know i think it's different from
the certainty of your mind
and then you can
oh i don't know what does it say for a
manifold
i don't know
i also don't know
really
course
and can you have a better boundary
mixing time
um i'm not sure i mean you can say
something different from the
mixtape so you can say
suppose lambda 2 is
not so big of the laplacian but
lambda k is big
so you can say that for many start
vertices
the
collision probability of the
distribution of the random walk
will
go down very quickly
and it will get to something like one
over
whatever k square over n or k over n
that doesn't mean that the random walk
is mixed but it means its entropy has
been increasing quickly
uh
after that
to get from there to
uh
uniform
it really depends on
lambda 2 in fact the graph could be
k expanders connected by just one edge
between them so immediately you get to
collision probability k over n
immediately log in time but then it will
take longer to move
it means that
there is key
measure that you will approach a
combination of this camera in fact
it should provide a way to prove this
car
is
do you have any structure theorem for
graphs in which lambda k is large or you
don't assume anything about the cap
uh yeah so
so if lambda k
is large
then
5k needs to be large
so then
um
but um
so either actually phi 2 is already
large and the graph isn't expanded
or there has to be some i between two
and k such as the gap between i and i
plus one and averaging arguments yeah
yeah but is there anything conceivably
stronger than that i just tell you that
lambda k is large
so i don't necessarily want a partition
or anything
but can you well um
i mean to me the return should be if
lambda is large
and we get this up to the precise
dependence on k if lambda k is large
there is some
k prime possibly smaller than k such you
can put you can partition the vertices
into k expanders yes exactly yeah
so we look at this because there will be
a
there will be some k prime between two
and k for for which this this gap is
large if uh k's large
all right let's have some tea all right